71% of the earth's surface is covered
with water why don't we make use of all
that underwater real estate
[Music]
what would it be like to live at the
bottom of the ocean where would we get
oxygen to breathe and foodie and what
would we do in case of an emergency
evacuation this is what if and here's
what would happen if we lived underwater
there is one thing standing between us
and underwater living our bodies aren't
adapted to it if you do 150 meters
underwater without proper training or
equipment your lungs would shrivel to
the size of a pop can and your veins
would collapse descending all the way to
the bottom of the ocean would feel as if
you are being crushed under 14 full
cement trucks but that doesn't mean our
dreams of underwater living can never
come true it just means we'd need to
dream smaller our underwater habitats
would be rather small populated with a
few thousand good swimmers at most we'd
live in small modules made of steel
glass and cement designed for underwater
use and instead of going too deep into
the ocean we'd settle about 100 metres
undersea we need to build life support
systems that would maintain air
composition temperature and humidity
keeping a livable amount of oxygen in
the air would be our major concern if we
wanted to make our habitat
self-sustaining we'd need to figure out
how to grow plants that would produce
their own oxygen how would we go about
powering up our ocean ville with
land-based solar panels that would
transmit energy to the habitats we could
also use wave power
the undersea equivalent of wind turbines
then there's food we'd rely heavily on
dehydrated and canned supplies but don't
forget about good old fishing with so
many foods swimming in front of you why
not take advantage of the fresh sea
market our drinking water would be
supplied through distillation or
condensation and all our waste would
most likely be flushed out into the
ocean underwater living isn't without
its dangers though imagine a worst-case
scenario
your bedroom window gets a massive crack
and water rampages through your living
space or your life-support system fails
leaving you to suffocate undersea in
order to stay safe we'd need to perform
regular evacuation drills and make sure
our emergency alert systems were up and
running at all times you'd be wise to
keep an oxygen tank on hand and have a
small submarine ready to shuttle you to
safety
the cool thing about all this is that we
already have the technology to make it
work although so far the longest an
individual has managed to live
underwater is 31 days there are
companies out there planning on building
an underwater city like this whether
it's safe enough is another question
may be building cities floating in the
air would be a more feasible option but
that's a story for another what if
you